this guy's an actor he's like a
very like a rookie actor and he said
that they're protecting
the camera but not the actual guys or
you know the you know the not so famous
actors on set
and then um that's the guy right there
ian they're saying he could be charged
with involuntary manslaughter
but that they say that for a [ __ ]
heaven yeah
and uh so i guess nicholas cage also was
upset with this girl the same girl that
was the armory person for the movie yeah
he said that she
like multiple times shot shot guns
without warning so super amateur yeah
in the business she had these jobs yeah
yeah she [ __ ] with my boy nicholas
cage
yep he looks crazy there he does look
really pretty there for sure
but she wouldn't warn people when she
would shoot rounds she would just do i
mean he would say like you almost blew
my eardrums
like let us know beforehand so she has
some sort of history this is according
to people on on set not you know too
young to be an armor yeah she's too
young i don't want a young person way
too young
i don't know i've never met an armor in
all my years who wasn't in their 50s or
60s i mean i it's such an important
thing man
it's like a livestream when i did the
the tax collectors had guns there they
were real ak-47s but they weren't you
know with real bullets yeah but the
people that control them were [ __ ]
former special forces like he was like
50 but he was like
six tours in iraq or something yeah no
doesn't mean that this girl this doesn't
mean this woman couldn't do something
she had her father was very famous in
the space she grew up around it it
this is a very young person and yeah i i
think a lot of that's been overhead yes
and a lot of this is on probably the
production it's on yes yeah stunt
coordinator it's on everybody man it's
on the second a.d
it's on the director it's
you know the stuff more than i'm sure i
do i've shot plenty of guns on set i
mean you're giving it you just trust
them but well this is the other thing
that happens i've never had an
experience other than this when you're
given the gun as the actor
the armor will always show you
will always show you and the director
and the stun coordinator that the the
gun is empty
the chamber is empty or that there's a
fire in the hole if you're shooting a
live round chamber like you said this
story on monday but say chamber yeah if
you're if you have a live
but the idea is
yep there you go bro yeah you worked at
a gun store but the old you had a real
gun on set is
so that actor even said that she was
she was under a lot of like pressure
even the apparently the director said
definitely don't have a real gun i know
so the director said like they're
rushing her so much that she was
actually doing a good job con
for them yeah they thought she was doing
a good job but
it's because the production was so fast
yeah she couldn't get everything handled
brian tell us one more time how to shoot
a gun on that guy you gotta shoot get
your [ __ ]
chamber one more time
chamber
chamber
do a lot of actors listen lock it and
load it yep
lock the camera off step away and then
don't you yell something like this one's
firing oh did you say this gun's cold
um i've never heard gun cold but yeah
cold or hot cold or hot it's cold or hot
yeah cold out